welcome to the tenth lecture of our
course on the physics of impossible
things last time we talked about time
machines time machines of course were
introduced to literature by HG Wells and
ever since they've been an extremely
popular device in science fiction
stories and movies and time machines
lead to the grandfather paradox time
travel is impossible since it leads to
contradictions if I go back in time and
shoot my grandfather I can never be born
and then never go back in time and so
this is a pretty strong form of
impossible it comes up pretty close to
absolute impossibility and there was
another version we saw the Telegraph
paradox sending information into the
past is impossible for the same reason
now we also talked about two highly
speculative ideas for evading the
paradoxes one was what we might call the
irresistible fate idea the paradoxes do
not occur because we are somehow
destined by the iron laws of logical
necessity never to create the paradoxes
in the first place and and the the
physicist version of this would be
Novikov self-consistency principle and
the other idea was the branching time
idea the paradoxes are not really
paradoxical since time can branch out
into many inconsistent paths and David
Deutsch has suggested that some ideas
and quantum theory may may allow this to
take place a basic conclusion however is
that time machines are impossible that
we cannot have causal loops circular
chains of cause and effect in this
lecture we're going to take a deeper
look at time and its relation to space
we're going to introduce some
fundamental ideas from Einstein's theory
of relativity
now Einstein's theory was a revolution
in physics
it involved a major redrawing of that
boundary between the possible and the
impossible and so we're going to need to
conduct a survey of that territory under
the under the new rules so for this
lecture we're going to spend most of our
time on the possible side many of the
things that we talked about may sound
impossible but all of them are confirmed
by experiments because relativity theory
is not mere speculation relativity is a
battle-tested theory of nature that
battle-tested theory leads to
far-reaching changes in our
understanding of space and time so our
job is going to be to learn to think of
the world as in relativity as
essentially four dimensional three
dimensions of space one dimension of
time space time relativity of course was
invented by Albert Einstein German
physicist he was later a Swiss citizen
than an American citizen Einstein of
course was one of the greatest
scientists of all time to this day he's
a popular icon and he made absolutely
brilliant contributions to statistical
physics he was a founder of quantum
theory but most famously Einstein was
the father of relativity theory in a
series of scientific papers beginning in
1905 when Einstein was a technical
expert third class at the Swiss Patent
Office culminating in his general theory
of relativity when he was a professor at
the University of Berlin in 1915
Einstein laid out the theory so so what
was he trying to do well we don't really
have time for the complete story of the
origins of relativity so I'll simplify a
little bit
basically in the late 19th century
several people had recognized that there
was a mathematical inconsistency between
two theories on the one hand you had
newton's laws of mechanics the laws of
force and motion and on the other hand
you had equations developed during the
19th century
scribing electric and magnetic fields
equations that were invented by James
Clerk Maxwell the problem focused on the
speed of light which is denoted by the
letter C C standing for the Latin term
celeritas meaning speed C is the speed
of light now light is an electromagnetic
wave it's a traveling disturbance of
electric and magnetic fields and so that
that wave is described by Maxwell's
theory and the theory predicts the
correct wave speed C of 300,000
kilometers per second 300,000 kilometers
per second but what if the experimenter
who is measuring the speed of light is
actually moving in motion what if the
laboratory is moving through space like
the earth in its orbit for example well
according to the Newtonian view an
observer in motion should measure a
different speed in different directions
for the speed of light now for from
Maxwell's theory the speed is C that's
it but that's the number in the 19th
century almost everyone including
Maxwell presumed that Newton is right
that that in fact Maxwell's equations
for electromagnetic theory will have to
be modified for observers in motion and
that observers in motion on the earth
say as it orbits around the Sun should
indeed measure different speeds of light
in different directions okay in the
1880s Albert Michelson and Edward Morley
a couple of American physicists did a
super-sensitive optical experiment to
detect this effect the fact that the
speed of light could be different in
different directions really the one of
the most sensitive experiments that had
ever been done and they should have seen
it but they find no such effect the
speed of light simply seems to be C
now in the late 19th century a number of
physicists try to tackle this problem
including on Reap Wonka Ray who really
almost got the answer right but the idea
wasn't clear until Einstein proposed a
radical solution Einstein proposed that
it was Newton's theory that needed to be
altered Maxwell's equations were right
Newton's theory must be altered the
speed of light says Einstein is really
the same for every observer whether or
not the observer is moving every
observer would measure the same speed of
light in their laboratory and Einstein
works out the implications of this idea
and his arguments are I have to tell you
they're brilliant they're lucid they're
simple but they're startling because
Einstein concludes that different
observers will simply disagree about
space and time measurements different
observers will disagree about the
distance between two events and the time
elapsed between two events in other
words Einstein concludes that
measurements of space and time are
relative to who measures them that's
that's the relative part of relativity
but but we shouldn't focus altogether on
the relative part because fundamental
things are the same for all observers
all observers see exactly the same laws
of physics including exactly the same
speed of light so in a way the theory is
really based on what must be the same
for everyone not what must be different
ok keep talking about the speed of light
what's so special about light what's
what's the special role that light plays
in relativity and the answer is nothing
light has no special role in relativity
the point is that this speed see 300,000
kilometers per second is a fundamental
speed in
the universe light happens to be one of
the things and not the only one that
goes at this fundamental speed see but
the value of see the value of that speed
affects everything for example we've
seen one of the consequences that
Einstein derived way back in lecture
four we talked about the relation
between mass and energy e equals
mc-squared the energy content of an
object is its mass times C squared the
square of the speed of light now what is
that relation between energy content and
mass have to do with light and the
answer is nothing in particular that
doesn't really have to do with the
phenomenon of electromagnetic waves it's
a fundamental relation based on the
fundamental speed see now we're still
gonna call C the speed of light for
convenience ah but but there's nothing
special about light except that it
happens to move at C and we're gonna see
more of the consequences of einstein's
idea next time but meanwhile we want to
take a look at a new point of view a
point of view that's implicit in
Einsteins work but in fact was
contributed by someone else and that
someone else was Hermann Minkowski
Hermann Mycoskie was a German
mathematician in fact he was one of I'm
Stein's professors at the Technical
University of Zurich and Minkowski was
complete completely deeply impressed by
Einsteins work on relativity and he
realized that relativity is really a
theory about the geometrical
relationship between space and time and
in 1908 Minkowski gave an amazing
lecture an amazing address called space
and time and I want to quote to you how
it starts it starts with ringing words
he says the views of space and time
which I wish to lay before you had
sprung from the soil of experimental
physics and therein lies their strength
they are radical henceforth space by
itself and time by itself are doomed to
fade away into mere shadows and only a
kind of union of the two will preserve
an independent reality that union of the
two is what Minkowski called space-time
now it's perfectly sensible to say that
the universe has four dimensions space
of three dimensions you want to specify
a point in space you need three numbers
so so near the surface of the earth for
example you might need your latitude and
your longitude latitude tells you east
west longitude tells you north south and
you'll need your altitude that'll tell
you where you are up and down and these
are in fact exactly the three numbers
that your electronic GPS unit might give
you to specify something that happens in
the universe though an event we also
need the time of the event we need one
more number so everything that happens
in the universe can be located by four
numbers three numbers for space and one
number for time and so we say that there
are four coordinates for space and time
that's what we mean when we say that the
universe is four-dimensional so space
and time together make space-time
everything that happens in the universe
is a part of space-time everything
happens some went where and some win so
so how are we going to think about
something in four dimensions how can we
visualize four dimensional geometry well
maybe some people can do this I know
physicists too who seem to be able to do
something very much like this but for
the rest of us we're going to have to
simplify and typically what we're going
to do is for purposes of explanation
well we'll typically pretend that that
space is one-dimensional or
two-dimensional well forget about that
third dimension of space and we'll draw
a picture that includes both space and
time relationships such a picture is
called a spacetime diagram now by
tradition
in a spacetime diagram we draw the time
Direction vertical with the future
pointing up so the time axis points
vertically and the space axes point
horizontally now it has one point about
these axes we typically measure time in
seconds and we measure space in meters
and makovski said this is like using
inches for measuring east-west distance
and miles for measuring north-south
distance that doesn't make sense so what
we really need to do is we need to
somehow measure time in meters how do we
do that how do we convert seconds to
meters well the way we do it is we
multiply by C the speed of light the
fundamental speed so many meters per
second and so one meter - of time one
meter of time this is one meter of space
so what's one meter of time look like
well that corresponds to about one 300
millionth of a second one three hundred
millionth of a second a meter of time is
not very long it's the time that it
takes light to go from here to here one
meter of space and so when we draw our
diagrams we may call our space-time axes
x + y + C T C times time okay so we we
can draw our space-time diagrams what
sorts of things are in space-time well
an event is just a point in space-time
it's aware and a win and what we would
call a moment in time would be a
horizontal plane including all the
points in space at a particular instant
of time we can think of space-time is
kind of a stack of moments in time one
upon another all stacked up into it into
a into a volume it's sort of like taking
the frames of a film and clipping the
frames apart in the film and then piling
them up one frame after the other to
form a solid block that solid block
would kind of contain the film so that
space-time now what is an ordinary
object like a particle look like in
space-time well in each moment the
particle has a location
space there's an event associated with
that particle particle here so the
particle in space-time is all of these
events taken together
I mean Koski says you have what he calls
a world line stretching from the past to
the future that represents a particle
and the motion of the particle is simply
the shape of that world line a particle
at rest it's a straight world line
straight up and down it's parallel to
the time axis at every moment in time
it's the same place of part of the same
location in space a particle in uniform
motion would be a straight world line
but tilted to one side at each moment in
time a slightly different place an
accelerating particle would be a curved
world line a particle moving in a circle
it's world line is a helix a kind of a
spiral reaching from the past to the
future if you had two particles
colliding then there'd be an event of
the collision event where the two world
lines would meet and maybe they'd Bend
and come out in different directions
well suppose instead of just a
point-like particle you had an object
with some size like a baseball or a
planet well then your world line would
have have some thickness what's
sometimes called a world tube so all at
all this is kind of an interesting view
of the world if you will and from the
space time point of view the world does
not exactly happen the past the present
in the future are all combined at once
in space-time all right
let's suppose that there's a flash of
light somewhere for example there's a
flash bulb pumping it was poof light
flies out in all directions
now our usual event would be that
there's a flash event and then
afterwards we could imagine there's an
expanding sphere of light the flash and
it expands outward at the speed of light
see now if we forget about one dimension
of space that would be like an expanding
circle moving outward like like the
ripples in a pond in space-time we would
take those circles and we'd stack them
up and we'd get a structure that
Minkowski called
the light-cone the point at the bottom
of the cone is the flash event the the
the place and time where the flash took
place and the sides of the cone are
drawn at a 45 degree angle why
well well light moves one meter of space
per meter of times that makes it 45
degrees in our picture so let's suppose
there's a flash event and I'm nearby
when and where do I see the flash well
event we'll call it event a is the event
where the light flash takes place the
point of the light cone and event B is
the event where I perceive the flash and
that's the point where my world line
intersect the light cone so the light
cone from a includes all the events and
space times that are reached by light
from a but of course we can also extend
the light cone back into the past
creating what we call the past light
cone and that includes all the events
from which light reaches a so so how do
I think about this well go out tonight
look at the stars if the if the if the
sky is clear and when you look at it the
Stars some of those stars are closer
than others and and from the more
distant stars light takes a longer time
to travel from the nearest stars takes a
few years the distance is a few light
years but other stars that you can see
are hundreds or thousands of light years
away it takes hundreds or thousands of
years for the light to reach you so
right now when you look out into into
the universe you're not seeing a moment
of time in the universe the Starlight is
years or centuries old and for distant
galaxies that you might be able to see
in a telescope the light is millions or
billions of years old astronomers say
this say it this way you're when you
look out into space you're also looking
back in time now in space time the where
and the wind of where you are they is is
the here and now an event a point in
space time here and now when you look
out into the sky what you always see
is the past light cone of here and now
farther out is also farther back in time
now events world lines and light cones
are the basic concepts of space-time and
Minkowski said Einstein's relativity is
really a theory about the geometry of
space-time that geometry is not quite
the same as Euclidean geometry I have to
tell you it has a different idea of
distance and and and that will help us
make sense of diagrams a little bit
later Minkowski gives some simple rules
for his geometry and and and then a
derives relativity from the rules of
geometry so what sign Stein's reaction
to his teachers idea well I have to tell
you he does not like it at first he
thinks it's it it doesn't sound right
but he soon changes his mind
spacetime he comes to believe including
that the region that includes all space
and all the time is the true arena for
physics to take place and the idea of
space-time affected Einstein's whole
outlook on life he later would say that
the passage of time is merely a stubborn
illusion and he liked to take a more
eternal point of view outside time where
all the times in the universe are
present together in space-time okay so
what's this business of different
observers what about the relativity in
relativity well different observers will
put different time and space coordinates
on the same space-time so consider two
observers Alice and Bob and Alice says
I'm at rest
Bob Bob's moving to the right and in the
spacetime diagram Alice's world line is
vertical
Bob's is tilted to the right now of
course if you ask Bob Bob will say look
I'm at rest Alice is moving to the left
and if you look at Bob's space-time
diagram Alice's world line is tilted to
the left
Bob's is vertical the two diagrams look
differ
but and here's the most important point
the two diagrams represent the same
space-time they're like maps with two
different coordinate systems showing the
same landscape there's only one
landscape and in the same way there's
only one space-time the set of all
events that happen different observers
assign different space and time
coordinates to the events in space-time
so let me illustrate this idea with a
little thought experiment what I want to
do is I want to imagine two simultaneous
events two events that happen at the
same time and and to make this clear I
want to I want to first figure out how
I'm going to make these two events
simultaneous so here's how I'm going to
do it I'm going to imagine I have three
devices that are equally spaced and
they're sitting here at rest and in the
center I have a flash bulb and at each
end I have a bell with a little
electrical device that will ring the
bell
when the light flash reaches the Bell
and then I'll set off the flash bulb
light will go out in each direction at
the same speed the speed see when the
light reaches each bail each bell will
ring and reaches the two bells at the
same moment so the two bells ring
simultaneously the ringing of the bells
simultaneous events now if I if I draw a
space-time diagram and I'll draw it in
two dimensions so so our light cones are
just a pair of diagonal lines I have the
world lines of the three devices and the
world lines are vertical because the
devices are at rest and the first event
is the firing of the flash bulb in the
middle and then the light cone angles
out from this event and there are two
more events the bell ringing events and
the bells ring at the same moment
they're on the same horizontal line the
same level in the space-time diagram
because the light from the flash event
reaches them at the same level the same
horizontal line the two events are
simultaneous
now I want to look at the same setup but
this time I'm going to suppose that the
devices are moving to the right now this
could be the same experiment observed by
someone moving to the left they would
see the the whole apparatus moving to
the right now the flash bulb flashes and
the light goes each direction at a speed
C remember it's the same speed as before
it's a fundamental speed of the universe
light always travels at C now the light
hits the left-hand Bell before it
reaches the right-hand Bell because the
left-hand Bell is catching up for the
light and the right-hand Bell is moving
away from the light and so that - bell
ringing events are not simultaneous the
left-hand Bell the trailing bell rings
first right-hand Bell a leading bell
rings second so let's take a look at the
space-time diagram the world lines of
the three devices are tilted since
they're moving and the first event is
the flash bulb going off in the middle
device the light cone sides are still at
45 degrees light still moves at the
speed C that's a universal number so the
two events are where the light cone
intersects the other two world lines and
those are where the bells ring those
bell ringing events happen at different
times the left-hand bell ringing is
lower happens earlier than the
right-hand ringing okay there are many
things to learn from this example first
of all two events which are simultaneous
for one observer are not simultaneous
for another observer this is what's
called the relativity of simultaneity
which was a profound insight of Einstein
different observers define space and
time relationships differently and this
is a really really important point
in fact the relativity of simultaneity
is the resolution of many of the seeming
paradoxes of relativity the apparently
paradoxical results can be resolved if
you just remember that simultaneity is
relative to the observer
the second thing I want to point out is
that these two space-time diagrams look
quite different each one of them's kind
of v-shaped you got a flash event and
two ringing events and got a light cone
but the two arms and the diagrams appear
to have equal lengths in one diagram but
not in the other diagram this is because
we've drawn our space-time in ordinary
space we've used the geometry of Euclid
to try to represent the geometry of
space-time but the geometry of
space-time is not the geometry of Euclid
it's its Minkowski geometry and the two
arms are actually the same in both
diagrams remember I said there was a
different definition of distance and
that finally brings us to the third
point each observer sees and each
diagram represents exactly the same
space-time there are the same world
lines the world lines of the three
devices they are the same events one
flash two rings there are the same light
cone relationships among the events so
despite the relativity of space and time
relationships there is only one
spacetime okay in this lecture we've had
a taste of Einstein's relativity and
we've had a look at Minkowski space-time
geometry different observers see the
same space-time but different observers
divide that space-time into space and
time in different ways and so an example
of that was that events which are
simultaneous same time for one observer
may not be simultaneous same time for
another observer two space-time diagrams
may look different to our Euclidean eyes
but they do represent the same
space-time world now next time we're
going to use all this to learn something
to learn about something impossible in
fact
nothing can travel faster than the speed
of light it's impossible well is that
true we'll see that in part it depends
on what we mean by a thing if no thing
can travel faster than light what do we
mean by a thing and when we investigate
this will actually find that this is
going to change what we mean by past and
future in the space-time world that's
next time I'll see you then
[Music]
[Music]